[Tone]
[Music]
[Narrator:] These are the wounded, sick, and
injured of the Navy.
They are being taken from wherever they were
hurt or fell sick, to naval hospitals where
they will get the best possible medical care.
[Music]
These men are suffering with everything from
wounds and burns received in battle,
to broken ankles from falling off a ladder cleaning windows.
Some are sick from physical causes, like heart
trouble or pneumonia.
Others are just as sick from mental causes,
the N.P. or neuro-psychiatric patients.
All sick people require treatment, but right
now you're chiefly interested in the treatment of the mentally ill.
These men are being admitted to the N.P. ward.
For the most part, they appear more or less
normal.
But if you look carefully, you will notice
that some of them show definite signs of their illness.
These patients are really sick.
Otherwise the doctors would have never sent
them to the hospital.
As hospital corpsmen, you will help in the
treatment of many types of mental illness,
and each one requires a different approach.
[Music]
[Speaker 1:] All right Miller, let's have
your wristwatch and wallet, because we're
going to give you a shower.
[Miller:] I lost my portable radio already.
[Speaker 1:] Well, all your stuff will be
put in this bag, which is numbered,
and then kept in a safe locker.
Everything you leave with us is listed right
down here, so we have a complete record.
[Miller:] But what about that radio?
[Speaker 1:] Oh, well I'll make a note of
that right now and I'll have the chief
send out a tracer on it.
And now Miller, let's get that uniform off.
A shower'll feel good after three days on
the train.
[Narrator:] Treatment of an N.P. patient begins
from the moment he arrives in the admitting room.
Everything that is done for him makes him
feel that the people in the hospital are friendly
and want to help.
Your manner, approach, and the way you handle
N.P. patients is of great importance.
Remember, they're more sensitive than those
who are physically ill.
[Speaker 2:] Right this way.
These are papers on Miller, sir.
[Speaker 2:] Thank you.
That's all.
Have a chair.
Your name is Miller?
How are you feeling, Miller?
[Miller:] Terrible.
I didn't sleep for three days.
[Speaker 2:] Well we'll try and help you get
some sleep here.
[Narrator:] This man looks dazed and slowed
down.
A condition which can develop either in boot
camp or in combat.
You've been in the dumps too, but you've always managed to snap out of it, because that's normal.
This man can't without help, any more than
he could set his arm if it were broken, or
take out his own appendix.
A smart corpsman can give him that help and
start him on the way to recovery.
[Speaker 3:] How about some chow?
Aw, c'mon, it looks pretty good to me.
[Miller:] I shouldn't be here.
I should be back with the ship.
I have no business here.
[Speaker 3:] You know Miller, the quickest
way to get back to the boys is by eatin' your chow.
Tastes good!
Here.
Try one.
Go on, try one.
Tastes good doesn't it?
Try some milk now.
[Miller:] I gotta get back to the ship.
[Speaker 3:] Sure, but the milk will taste
good with those spuds.
[Narrator:] This corpsman is doing a darn
good job.
He is firm, but kind, so as not to irritate
the patient.
The next time it will be easier for both of
them, and the patient has made another step to recovery.
While Miller is having his first square meal
in days, let's get a few things straight about N.P. patients.
First of all, the patient is never batty or
nuts.
He is sick and must be treated as such.
Take Miller.
He isn't stubborn or unreasonable because
he doesn't want to eat.
That's just a symptom of his particular illness
and the corpsman used the right approach.
Not all N.P. patients will be the same.
There are many different types of mental illness, and we are going to show you a few
you will be seeing most.
Some will be slowed down, like Miller.
Others, tense and on edge, like cases of psychoneurosis
or combat fatigue.
You will see the unreliable psychopath, the
very depressed, suicidal patient, and the catatonic.
Some may be mixed up and excited, others overactive
with more energy than they can use.
In each case, the symptoms will be different
and all require different treatment.
It is the corpsman, rather than the doctor,
who will be with the patient most of the time.
And for that reason, the corpsman must know his patients, watch their behavior and report
anything unusual.
The corpsman is the eyes and ears of the doctor.
Here's what I mean.
How did Harris get along last night?
I'm afraid he didn't get much sleep, even
with the sodium amytal you prescribed.
He seems awfully restless and confused this
morning.
Hmm, better have him see me the first thing
after sick call.
How's Miller today?
Oh, he's getting along fine, sir.
He ate everything we gave him and wanted more.
[Narrator:] Information about the patient's
behavior is being given to the doctor so he
can follow the case closely.
Take Miller for instance.
The doctor is now ordering him a needle shower and spray, and hydrotherapy as part of his treatment.
[Sounds of water running in shower.]
[Corpsman operating water hoses:] Step back a little, will you, Miller?
[Sound of water spraying powerfully on Miller's
back.]
[Narrator:] There is another type of patient
you will see, and probably quite a few.
Some will be in hospitals, but most will be
treated in naval convalescent centers.
This type of patient may not seem particularly
sick to you, but he may be a psychopath,
a case of psychoneurosis, or combat fatigue.
This kind of patient is usually tense, nervous, jittery, and often makes a tough problem to manage.
Take combat fatigue, for example.
[Corpsman Al:] Get up, Mac, get up!
[Mac:] What the hell you think you're doing?
[Al:] You're supposed to hit the deck with
the others and I'm here to see that you do.
[Corpsman Bob:] What's the trouble?
[Mac:] This jerk's trying to get me up.
You know I can't sleep nights, and when I
finally do fall asleep he tries to push me out, for God's sake.
[Bob:] Aw, take it easy, fella.
Al here is new, he won't do it again.
But don't forget, you're still in the service
and we've got rules here whether we like them
or not.
Besides, you're going to get well a lot quicker
if you follow the gang.
Now get out there with your mates.
You've missed breakfast already.
[All:] I don't see why we have to baby these
goldbricks.
[Bob:] He's no goldbrick.
He won a unit citation.
You don't have to baby them, just use your
head.
Now watch this.
That may help.
Time to get up, Ed.
Ed, time to get up.
[Ed:] What's the matter?
[Bob:] Why, everybody's up and out.
You've missed breakfast.
[Ed:] Aw, nuts.
[Bob:] If you hurry, you can get a cup of
coffee.
[Al:] Maybe you've got something there.
[Bob:] They probably couldn't sleep last night.
Lots of things patients do here seem like
plain goldbricking and bellyaching, but they're
not.
They're symptoms of whatever they've got.
They may act nasty and insulting at times,
but just keep your sense of humor
and don't forget that if you get tough with
them, they'll make your job that much harder.
[Al:] I guess you're right.
[Bob:] Same goes for the psychopath.
He can be a real troublemaker and requires
plenty of watching.
I nearly got fooled by one yesterday.
[Kern:] Hello, Bob, check me out, will you?
[Bob:] Why sure.
Have you got your liberty pass?
[Kern:] Well, uh Doctor Adams said he'd have someone leave it for me at the main gate.
I just saw him.
[Bob:] He said it'd be all right?
[Kern:] Sure.
'Til six tonight.
Hey, I'll get to see a double-header today.
[Bob:] Just a minute fella.
I'd better check with Doctor Adams.
[Kern:] Oh, well Doctor Adams won't be in...
[Bob:] Hello, Doctor Adams.
Why, this is Davis in ward seven, sir.
Did you tell Kern he could leave the hospital
today, sir?
I see.
Aye, aye, sir.
Sorry, Doctor Adams says no.
[Kern:] I don't understand it.
I just left him.
Who the hell does he think he is, anyway?
[Narrator:] Well that patient was a pretty
good liar, but a little challenged when he was caught.
You've probably seen psychopaths just like
that, outside of hospitals too.
Because there are lots of them, and lying
is only one of their symptoms.
One of the most important parts of the corpsman's
work is the protection of patients.
Sometimes from others, and sometimes from
themselves.
If the patient is depressed enough, he may
even attempt suicide.
That is why he may be put in a room with a
special watch.
Not for punishment, but for protection.
[Roberts:] No use.
It's no use going on.
I ought to be dead.
Oh my God, it's no use at all.
[Corpsman assisting him:] Is there anything
I can do for you?
[Roberts:] Oh my God, nothing anybody can
do for me.
I don't rate it, I don't rate anything in
the whole world.
[Corpsman assisting:] Well, is there anything I can get for you?
[Roberts:] No...I, I would like my mother's
picture that I brought here with me.
[Corpsman assisting:] All right, then I'll
get it for you right away.
Roberts up on F-6 said he has his mother's
pictures in his gear, you want to look it
up for me please?
[Inventory man at desk:] Sure.
[Corpsman assisting:] He wants the picture
pretty bad.
Poor kid, feels about as low as he can.
I hope this picture helps him some.
[Inventory man:] Roberts?
Isn't he the one we're supposed to keep an
eye on?
[Corpsman assisting:] Yeah, that's the guy.
[Inventory man:] Is he alone now?
[Corpsman assisting:] I suppose so.
I just come down here for a minute.
[Inventory man:] Yeah, but it might be the
wrong minute.
He could kill himself in that minute.
That man is supposed to get a shock treatment this morning, and he has a darn good chance of getting well.
Oh, he probably wants his mother's picture
all right, but he might want this glass, too.
And broken glass can be awful sharp.
You better get back up there on the double.
[Corpsman assisting:] Okay.
[Narrator:] When men are sick and depressed
like Roberts, you've got to be on a constant
lookout for anything they could use to hurt
themselves.
Glass in any form, medicine bottles, eyeglasses,
or anything that will make a sharp edge.
Remove all belts, neckerchiefs, scarves.
Watch out for knives, razor blades, or anything
that will cut.
You may never see a patient as depressed as
that.
But if you do, remember Roberts and his mother's
picture.
Fortunately for him, there are several ways
of treating his condition.
One of the most successful is the electroshock
treatment.
[Roberts:] Oh!
Oh my God!
I can't.
I don't.....uhhhh.
[Supervisign doctor:] This will help you to
get well.
[Roberts:] Nothing will help me to get well.
Ohhhh...
[Supervising doctor:] Ready?
[Roberts screams, then convulses as the shock
treatment is administered.
He trembles and moans.
Medical staff assist the patient.]
[A manual lawnmower creaks as it's pushed
across the lawn.]
[Bob:] Kind of hot pushing that thing around,
isn't it?
[Roberts:] Oh not too bad.
The exercise feels good.
[Bob:] How're the treatments going along?
[Roberts:] Oh I'm through with them.
Had six, the doctor says I don't need anymore.
Guess I was pretty sick when I started taking
those treatments.
I don't even remember.
[Bob:] Well, it's good to see you looking
so well.
[Narrator:] It's things like that that give
you kick out of working around an N.P. ward.
To know you helped that man recover makes
you feel good.
Of course, not all patients will recover so
rapidly.
A lot of them will may take weeks or even
months, so don't get impatient.
Another type of patient you may help treat
is the catatonic.
He may stay like this for hours, or days without
moving, eating, or even speaking.
But he hears and understands everything.
[Another corpsman assigned to help catatonic man:] All right Harris, we're going to see the doctor now.
Okay Harris, we're just going down the hall.
[Doctor:] Is that seven and half grams?
[Nurse:] Yes sir.
[Corpsman:] Take it easy, Harris.
The doctor wants to talk to you.
[Doctor:] Sodium amytal please.
It's all right, Harris, this will make you
feel better.
This medicine will help you to relax so you
can talk to us.
All you'll feel is the prick of the needle.
Tourniquet off.
I want you to talk to us, Harris.
We want to help you, but you won't tell us
what's wrong.
You know we want to help you to get well,
don't you?
[Harris:] I know everything happening here.
[Doctor:] That's fine.
Then tell us what's worrying you and why you can't talk.
[Harris:] They tell me not to.
[Doctor:] Who tells you not to?
[Harris:] The voices.
[Doctor:] You see, you can talk.
[Harris:]I guess I can.
[Doctor:] About these voices.
When do you hear them?
[Harris:] Mostly at night, just as I go to
bed.
[Doctor:] Are they male, or female voices?
[Harris:] Male.
There's one that keeps threatening me.
[Narrator:] Starting with this treatment,
and helped by various others, the patient
will continue to get better,
sometimes in a matter of weeks.
[Bob:] Well, how's everything today, Harris?
[Harris:] Okay!
Got a light?
[Bob:] Sure.
[Harris:] Was I really nuts when they brought me here?
[Bob:] Well, what do you think?
[Harris:] Guess I was pretty sick.
[Bob:] Yes you were.
Plenty sick.
It must be nice to feel like yourself again.
[Harris:] It sure is!
When do you think I can go downtown to see
a football game?
[Bob:] Well, I don't know, but I'll talk to
the doctor about it today.
[Harris:] Swell!
Thanks.
[Narrator:] The corpsman played a large part in the recovery of that patient, and still does.
He was honest, and not too optimistic in his
answers.
You'll get questions all day long from patients.
So if you don't know the answer, the safest
thing to say is 'I don't know,
but I'll try and find out.
One of the most serious problems on the N.P. ward is the mixed-up patient who becomes excited
and assaultive.
[Officer:] Good morning, Charlie.
[Charlie:] Well, go ahead.
Go ahead and shoot me.
[Officer:] I'm not going to shoot you, Charlie.
[Charlie:] Oh yes you are.
You're a policeman and it's your duty.
[Officer:] C'mon let's go.
It's time you took a little rest.
[Charlie:] No, I can't rest.
I deserve to be shot.
[Officer:] No you don't Charlie.
Come along, let's lie down.
[Charlie:] You've got to shoot me.
I'm yellow!
[Sounds of a scuffle as Charlie yells and
attacks the officer.]
[Officer:] It's all right, Charlie.
Take it easy.
[Bill:] Can I help?
[Officer:] Yeah, open the door, Bill.
[Narrator:] No matter how tough and unreasonable
a patient is, he must never be manhandled.
If you are ever in a spot like this, get as
much help as you can.
Lift the patient off his feet, take off his
shoes, and carry him into a strong room.
Then call the doctor immediately.
[Click of door being unlocked.]
[Doctor:] What seems to be the trouble, Jones?
Don't you want to talk to me about it?
Better get him down to hydro for a cold pack.
[Corpsman assisting doctor:] Yes sir.
[Older man in street clothes:] How do you
feel this morning?
[Charlie:] Not so good.
[Man:] Well, the doctor's ordered a treatment
for you again this morning.
You'll feel better after you get your treatment.
Get him good and tight down to the foot, please.
Want to raise your head, Charlie?
All right.
How's that?
Comfortable?
[Charlie:] Feels pretty good, thanks.
I'm going to go to sleep now.
[Narrator:] There's another type of overactive
patient.
But he is not so mixed up.
He has more energy than he can use sensibly
and takes careful handling.
Like most N.P. patients, if handled improperly,
he will behave improperly.
If you forget that he is a patient and you
are a corpsman, anything can happen.
[Bennett:] Say, these aren't the magazines
you promised me.
Where they hell are they?
[Corpsman at desk:] For about the tenth time,
Bennett, I'm telling you I'll see about them
as soon as I possibly can.
Now don't bother me, I'm busy!
[Dramatic music and the sound of glass breaking.]
[Narrator:] This patient can be calmed down
by continuous tub and hydrotherapy.
[Chief doctor:] How's the temperature running
Jim?
[Corpsman in hydro room:] It's running about
98 degrees, chief.
[Chief:] Better raise to a hundred.
The man's been pretty excited this morning.
[Hydro corpsman:] Okay.
[Narrator:] Now all his extra horsepower can
be used on something constructive and helpful.
[Music]
To get the patient back into an organized
routine where he feels himself a member
of the group is another part of your job.
Under the supervision of the doctor, occupational
therapist, and corpsman,
organized activities like these will help
most patients recover.
[Music]
I haven't got time to show you in detail the
many things you may be doing as an N.P. corpsman,
but I'd like to include a few.
You may help the doctor in the EEG room by
taking a record of the patient's brainwaves.
The corpsman is checking the electrodes before
making a record.
These tracings often give the doctor valuable
information in certain brain disorders.
You will be expected to take the patient to
the psychologist, where careful tests are
are given to measure intelligence or test certain skills.
You may have to take him across the country
on a train.
Aboard a ship.
Or in a plane.
Under travel conditions, what you have learned
becomes more important than ever.
There is about five times as much chance for
suicide, escape, or injury while traveling.
Remember, here you're on your own and don't
have the protection of the hospital ward to
help you.
When he gets better, you may have to take
him shopping.
Or you may take several patients to a ball
game.
Or the theater.
Your job may seem tough at times, but men
with your special training are needed.
When your shipmates leave the hospital happy
and well again,
there's a lot of satisfaction in knowing you've
done your part.
[Corpsman at desk:] Here's your wristwatch.
[Miller:] Thanks!
You know I got a 30-day leave.
[Desk corpsman:] Glad to be going, eh?
[Miller:] You bet!
Not that you fellas haven't been all right.
[Desk corpsman:] Thanks.
Here's something else that came in yesterday.
You must've left it on the train.
[Miller:] Say that's swell.
You guys never forget things do ya?
This'll come in handy on that 30-day leave.
[Desk corpsman:] Yeah.
[Miller:] Well, thanks.
Thanks for everything.
[Desk corpsman:] Sure.
Good luck.
[Miller:] Be seeing you.
[Desk corpsman:] Right-o.
[Music]